do you see this video where the antifa
guy is trying to climb the chase bank
yeah what yeah he tried that was rough
he hit the ground do you can you play
that are you gonna play it uh i'll
search for it he hit the ground and then
all of a sudden
he started to bleed i put in air clothes
but no no it's like a it's black paint
but it looks like blood
man yeah i really don't like it no he
was gonna
vandalize this building with black paint
and he fell and landed on his head
everywhere the paint starts dripping out
i was like oh it looks like oil or
something like he's a robot at first and
i mean then this girl's like he's like
this guy comes up and he's like what
happened where did he fall from she was
like
he landed on his hip he was like he fell
off from his hip she was like
he landed nevermind he didn't want to
say he didn't want to tell him so
we have this from andy now from andy no
tweets at a far left anti-capitalism
protest today at chase bank in manhattan
a masked protester falls after
attempting to climb the building
the black paint he was carrying is
spilled all over the ground so i'm not
going to show the actual
because youtube doesn't want us to but
i'll show you him climbing because
apparently that's okay
and then there's people yelling him get
down he's not that high i'm sorry
he's like eight feet up yeah he's like
eight feet up all right
and then he tries to grab onto the to
the uh
the awning falls down his paint
splatters here's my favorite part
call 9-1-1 immediately isn't it funny
you know i thought about this check it
out yeah the guy slammed like why not a
social worker
no no here's what i love but yes yes yes
uh what i love about this is
imagine it's like 1870 and a guy is
climbing the front of a bank
and he's like dude with capitalism and
then he falls and hits
his pelvis you know the people around
him would do but i just walk away
yeah call for help they just leave
they're like
my hip is broken no one's gonna do
anything they're gonna they're gonna
walk away from him
it's it's amazing that we're in today's
today's day and age and it's so so
pampered
that these these larpers are like i'm
going to claim the chase manhattan
it was like the the chase manhattan
security guard i can't confirm that
that he worked for chase but it was the
same guy looked like a security guard
for the building was like we've called
the ambulance don't worry
it's like the dude is just about to
vandalize your building you gotta do the
right thing right
you know what man we see we're so
tolerant and and accepting of this
behavior
i i get it what are we supposed to do we
can't just leave someone there but i'll
tell you this
when i saw that i'm sorry i'm gonna i'm
gonna say it i laughed a hearty laugh
you know why
because i've fallen from higher and i
watched jake brown
fall from two stories at the x games
slam onto his hip
get up and walk out waving while
everyone cheered for him
so like so for those of us aren't
familiar with what happened there that's
it was in the 2007 i think it was or
maybe 2006 x games
jake brown's on the mega ramp it's like
a hundred feet high dropping
then he launches like 70 feet then he
goes up a 20-foot vert wall
he's like 48 feet in the air he loses
control and slams into the deck
his shoes fly like 50 to 100 feet just
crazy
and everyone thought he was dead i
watched it live and we were just like oh
my god
and then he he they walk over to him
they check out his neck and everything
they lift him up and then he he limps
out waving to the crowd
wow this antifa guy falls eight feet and
he's going oh
they're like what's wrong my hip he's
frail okay he's frail
nice you need to drink more milk yeah
yeah well it's it's
there's this weird thing where people
have survived falls from
extreme heights but then some people
will fall like literally five or six
feet and they'll
sever their spine and die like it's
happened it's really horrible and scary
um my friend was in the military and he
was telling me about someone in his unit
who was a paratrooper
and his parachute did not open when he
jumped out of the plane and his backup
didn't open
and he landed and he survived he
basically shattered all of his bones but
yeah he survived the fall which isn't
insane
yeah apparently there's like techniques
you can do i guess they say aim for
trees yeah the way you land
oh yep better than oh man yeah let me
let me let me tell you all story let's
let's talk about some skateboarding see
uh i was like 16 and i was skating at a
skate park and there was this uh um
we'll just call it a box it was like it
five feet high
five you know five feet off the ground
and then from the top of it
there was a gap over another ramp which
is about five feet
i spent about an hour i'm 16. i'm trying
to do what's called the backside 180
over
this five foot high five foot long gap
to the ground
backside is when you're spinning and you
can't see where you're going because
you're looking behind you
i think i fell like 30 times and every
time i hit the ground i'd slip out or
i'd you know roll
and then finally i landed rolled away
all clean and everyone's like uh they're
all cheering for me
and then literally like a minute after
that some like seven-year-old kid was
jumping up and down and frolicking with
his mom slipped
on the ground in front of the ramp and
broke his ankle oh geez
and that's when i was like man that
weird it's crazy how like i can jump off
this on purpose
for like 30 you know 30 tries and each
time i fall hit the ground i just bounce
and roll away and get up and i'm like i
want to try it again well like they're
just such a strange thing like they're
so my brothers were both in a car
accident
probably about 10 years ago now uh on
the highway while they were doing 80 and
the car was like
completely totaled and they had their
seat belts on and thank god they
survived
there are people who end up like
permanently brain damaged after a
literal fender bender
it's just it's crazy you never know yeah
dude it's legit
yeah some people like will bang their
head just a little bit unlike the window
and then it's just like
causes damage but uh are we are we
basically saying that this antifa guy
has been severely injured and we must
you know
i have no idea maybe he got really hurt
i don't know pardon me
did not want ems or anything i was like
that
that vandal deserves to lay there in
pain but that was like a mean
part of me i don't know yeah the way you
want to take care of your enemies as
well like the woman i love your enemies
who they are yeah we we
you know in in the movie the patriot
with mel gibson
he tends to both sides after the battle
and then
the british you know because they're
evil and they always will be the red
cards exactly
basically you know burn his house down
love you because they did it i'm kidding
about the pretzels you've evolved well
apparently
we know you hate the bread apparently
you know there's a big controversy i
guess
because in that in that movie they
depict the british as like
really brilliant way over the top yeah
and so they like make them nazis yeah no
for real like he kills his kid
yeah he's like you tended to the wounded
kill her son
yeah jealous is great at propaganda
[Laughter]
it was such american propaganda that
movie good movie yeah i mean
you know that's of american problem no
the truth is the
the the british empire had power and
they were
basically the state and telling the
americans who were like yo leave us
alone what to do and so conflict breaks
out
but anyway i think what are we talking
about we get into this we have no idea
treating the wound oh yeah yeah so
actually
i'm conflicted on this too because
there's a difference between like
understanding there's a conflict in a
war and these people who keep
doing this stuff they don't stop and
what happens is they set fires
they break things they don't get
arrested in fact we render aid to them
yeah and so i understand i would never
let a person just sit there if they were
truly injured i'd
call them you know medical team i'm just
pointing out the the difficulty here and
how do you stop someone
from doing something dumb like trying to
climb chase while they're screaming get
down
and then he gets hurt and we're like who
all saw that coming yeah well that's the
thing i mean
treat them but they should face the the
full consequences that are due to them
legally like we should be arresting
these people of course don't let
anything
yeah but it's the prosecutors and i'll
tell you this man
we've had a bunch of conversations in
the past couple of weeks where i've been
like tax the rich
not literally but i'm just saying stop
billionaires from influencing politics
and i i get a lot of pushback you know
like uh we got i get pushback for you
by jack murphy michael mallis and they
don't they didn't agree with me on that
one but my issue is these district
attorneys
they're getting put in office through
the money of these ultra wealthy
progressive billionaire types not all of
our progressives i don't agree with any
one of these billionaires just flooding
the zone with money and shutting out
the opinions of the actual people who
live there but when people are just
swept up with hundreds of millions of
dollars in propaganda these da's
get elected we know that you know george
soros for instance it was was donating a
lot to a lot of the district attorneys
that's just a conspiracy theory tim i
don't know why you would never it's also
his name i want everyone to know that i
like having a youtube channel and i
denounced him right now seriously
anything about george soros it's true
well i'll tell you this it was the it
was
the mercers the koch brothers it's
george soros it's bezos
it's mackenzie bezos it is uh tom steyer
michael bloomberg
all of these ultra wealthy people dump
money into politics
and one of the big things we saw was
that uh uh i believe
this is really funny like fox news i
think newt gingrich was on it was like
you know george soros foundation was
helping to get these district attorneys
elected and then
fox was like we don't we don't we don't
say that around here and then people
were like that's a
fact that's so funny apparently you
can't even say the guy's name anyway
that's creepy the
look the point is i don't like the
billionaires the millionaires and the
billionaires
is doing this because then listen listen
these people do dumb things they get
arrested and the newly elected d.a is
very progressive goes you're free to go
that's correct no charges it's crazy
there should be some oversight
you can't name soros if i had only read
one single book in my entire life i
might compare him to voldemort
[Laughter]
he was self-made right george soros
didn't he come from well look like
a lowly the left apparently the only
book they've ever read are harry potter
that's true all they ever reference are
harry potter and the handmaid's tale
both of which are movies or exist in
visual media so it's like i know you
didn't even read them yeah
literally it's like the movie the only
literature they quote like exists on
television did you guys ever i don't
know
no dune you gotta read it aren't they
making this when's that new movie coming
out soon
no it's been they made a movie with with
sting in the early 80s yeah i saw that
one they made a made for tv movies with
william hurt which is way better that's
weird yeah the
the movie with the david lynch movie was
a little off oh yeah you told us to
watch it didn't you
not the david well watch it for
weirdness but the made for tv movie is
way better
but the book the book i heard the book
was good yeah that was what i was
talking about it's
basically this kid this this these
this king and his son his family would
have to flee the planet and they go are
they leave the planet and they go to
this new planet that's a desert planet
where that to harvest the spice there's
just like this galactic
spicy trade trade item and um there's
like conflict over the
over the spice the political conflict i
thought there's gonna be something like
an
analogous to you know antifa no it's
just such a great book that all these
i guess harry potter's great dune read
dune it is political maybe there's
something to it
these people just don't read books man
well this is my favorite thing i saw
this meme a while ago and it was like
comparing
trump and harry potter instead just like
troll left these it was very funny but
it was like favorably comparing trump to
harry potter and people were spreading
it around
i thought that was hilarious so who in
that context who's voldemort
probably hillary probably maybe soros i
don't know i don't know yeah
no come on i'm not into harry potter
what are we talking about
i love how like at this protest they're
holding up a big band of solidarity
and i'm like what what is that what
protest at the one where the guy climbs
the wall and then falls and and hurts
himself oh my gosh they're like holding
a big band it's a solidarian i'm like do
people like know what
you're talking about for real protests
the banking establishes a problem but
painting black stuff on their windows
isn't that's going to show them
yeah that won't get the cops to come out
and crack down
no i can just imagine you know the ceo
you know jamie dimon sitting in the i
don't know if he's still see you or
whatever probably
and then he looks he looks on the tv he
he looks out from the hundredth floor of
whatever building he's in
and he sees tiny little dots and he goes
what are they doing is that
is that black paint on my window what
have i done
and then he goes oh push the button
and he hits a button and the building is
electrically charged and the guy's
electrocuted and falls off the building
and everyone just thinks he slips what
happened
oh my god that explains everything
like when that when when the guy tells
the story about what happened it's very
dramatic
he's like and he's all my muscles seized
up at once and his version of it he's
super ripped and he's like
he's like 100 feet in the air and then
jamie dimon punched him in the face
you'll pay for this diamond
planes are flying by
all right anyway there are better ways
to protest the banks
keep that in mind guys yeah i've always
maintained a lot at the fed
damaging a window does nothing to
anybody but the people have to clean it
what is this guy did you guys see this
guy suing the federal reserve
have you guys looked into that i think
he's going to win ian i think he might
i think he might have a chance yeah he's
gonna sue them for everything they have
and they're just gonna keep printing and
printing and printing and he's gonna be
the wealthiest person who ever lived
did you guys see ryan long's not antifa
window repair
yes that was hysterical that was just
hysterical
so he's they have shirts that say not
antifa window repair
and he's like we we like figured out a
way to maximize profits while we're in
you know protesting
and they have antifa shirts and take
they take them off and it's like not
auntie for window repair and he's like
basically we go out organize these
protests so everyone smashes the windows
and then we're right there to pick up a
business
and then they actually went into bodegas
and like talk to them like we'll fix
your windows if they're you know if they
get smashed out
yeah good stuff good uh good comedy yes
good ryan long
comedy he's a genius thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you